- It is great that you're
doing iCarly again.
Did you think you would ever
do this again, like a reboot?
(audience cheering)
- I didn't.
- Yeah.
It's such a popular show.
- Yeah, it's been so much fun.
We just finished the third season
and there's this whole love story
that's been going on on the show
since I was 13 when I first started it
between my character Carly and
my friend Freddy on the show.
This whole season is all about our love.
- I love that.
- It's been a fun season.
- What a cool thing with a cast
to know since you were
a kid and growing up,
that's kind of cool.
- Yeah, we really grew up
together so it's crazy.
Nathan who plays Freddie on
the show has two daughters now
and is married and it's just crazy.
- So different.
- Being with someone your whole life,
hanging out with someone like that.
It's really nice.
- Well the original show
was for tweens and teens,
but do you ever get parents saying,
"Oh my God, I love your show?"
Because as a parent
I've actually watched this
show with kiddos before
and it's kind of cool when you make a show
that parents can sit there with their kids
and watch and you like it as well.
You're not like, "Oh this again."
That's kind of cool.
Do you ever hear from
parents in that sense?
- Yeah, sometimes parents
will come up to me
and it's really nice
'cause now that the show is
for the original viewers
and they've all grown up
a lot of people will
come up to me and say,
"I'm 30 now and I've been
watching it with my dad again."
Or, "I've been watching
it with my mom again."
And that feels really good.
It's something they did
when they were young
and now they can do it again with them.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you're
helping people connect.
That's cool.
- [Miranda] It's really nice.
- Yeah.